This kid puts on quite a show
I have eyes on the target.
He does not look all that threatening.
Looks can be deceiving, Your Highness.
Are you sure you do not want any backup?
No. I'm great with kids.
You thought the story was over,
but it was only just beginning.
I don't do sequels
normally,
but things have gotten a little twisted
in the multiverse.
Who is this handsome dog?
I've been looking for you
for a long time.
Die! Just be careful.
I don't think I can bear to narrate
what might happen next.
Darcy, We got a Code Red.
The Avengers towers been overtaken on Christmas.
What is this corner?
No, wait.
Under siege.
No, no, that's not it. Hey, John McClane, focus.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Marvel dropped a brand new
what if season 2 trailer
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs,
obviously a whole bunch of new episodes.
And the way they're releasing
episodes is totally different this year,
they're basically doing like an advent
calendar of what if season two?
There's nine episodes.
They start on December 22nd and they're going to air
like one episode every single day.
that's why in the official poster,
it seems like a holiday themed poster
because they're basically releasing it
right around Christmas, like the end of the year.
We already know what all the episode titles are.
So we have like a pretty good idea of what the
theme of each episodes are sort of a pretty good idea
of where the footage falls in which episode,
but there are a couple of question marks
it'll be a little bit harder.
But I'll do videos for all the episodes
every single day that they come out.
budget
starting at the beginning of the trailer footage.
The first scene is of the 1980s version of The Avengers
with like all the Avengers
heroes who would have been around during that time,
with one exception Thor,
who looks exactly the same
because it's like 100 years old in present day.
So of course
he'd look the exact same in this episode is from
What if Peter Quill attacked Earth's mightiest Heroes?
But it's the little kid
Peter Quill, who was actually taken to his father
ego the living plan back during the 1980s
when he was still a little kid.
so he's got all of his celestial powers.
He's going back to planet Earth to conquer.
And they're just like, well, a little kid, he's
not going to be that big of a problem.
but he's got crazy celestial powers, which they soon
realize you also just later in the trailer
there's like an eighties looking version of Ego
The Living Planet that's why he looks so much younger
the only weird thing about that
during the Guardians of the Galaxy two movie is ego.
The living planet is basically timeless,
like he's functionally immortal,
so he can look like whatever he wants to look like.
So it is weird that he looks like older Kurt Russell,
even though he doesn't have to look like he's older.
look. He could look like he does during the 1980s.
You're all young for the rest of time.
If you want to do.
But on this 1980s Avengers team
you have the Winter soldier
because he was still around
getting on Thor ID periodically during that era.
obviously you look the exact same Hank Pym is the main
version of Ant-Man still because he was younger
and still very active during that period as Ant-Man
and the WASP with his wife, Janet Van Dyne.
this version of Captain Marvel, though, is actually
Wendy Lawson from the first Captain Marvel movie.
You remember that Marvel was pretending to be her?
So I don't know if this is meant to be
the actual Marvel character who just acting
as their Captain Marvel.
it kind of sounds a little bit like Annette
Bening's voice, but I don't know if it's actual
Annette Bening coming back to play the character
or just a soundalike actor.
and they basically come to this fairground
where a young Peter Quill,
using a celestial powers,
is just grabbing all the toys that he wants.
Notice that they are raccoons for Rocket Raccoon,
pilot of Guardians of the Galaxy Easter Eggs.
During this But this is meant to be long
before he met the other Guardians characters.
you notice, the jet that they're flying in seems like
an early version of what the Quin jets wound up being.
Kind of like a black bird.
it's kind of the same vibes with the Jet from X-Men
Animated series, like the classic X-Men comics
then they reveal the king to Chaka, who is Black
Panther during this period was on that Avengers team.
That's T'challa's father. What?
Hank Pym says, he's great with kids.
He's talking about his daughter,
who is still a young girl during this period.
then when they land and they start battle
with this young version of Celestial
Peter Quill, you actually see Goliath behind them.
Remember, they teased this during Ant-Man and the WASP.
Bill Foster was part of Shield
during the 1980s and 1990s.
I think he left during the 1990s is the idea.
but he was basically the Goliath character
from the comics who acts kind of like Giant man
during that era.
I couldn't detect any big changes
in this Marvel Studios intro logo.
It's based on the logo from the first season
for the most part.
like a sort like the regular Marvel Studios logo.
And then it turns into an animated version of the logo.
then we see scenes from another episode called
What If Hella Found The Ten Rings.
And here's what's going on with this episode.
It's not quite what people expected.
It's actually like what it hella wound up turning good
instead of completely finding the ten rings
and taking over the planet.
the whole idea is that hella,
instead of getting banished to that prison
like the pocket dimension by Odin in the distant past
before Thor was born, is actually banished to Earth.
Kind of like Thor got banished to Earth
when he was found unworthy of the hammer in his armor,
Basically giving HeLa a version of the events
of the first Thor movie for herself.
But much earlier in the timeline, it seems like
so the whole idea here is that she actually finds
the same village from the Shang.
She moves in that other dimension where the dragon is.
They wind up taking her in
and she winds up learning their ways.
So it's kind of like hella master of kung fu.
But she has all of her regular powers as well to
Then it seems like Oden comes to Planet Earth
and it actually seems like she's fighting with
Wenwu here in the ten rings.
And that's where they sort of fulfill the title.
Like what if Helen found the ten Rings
and it's when Wu With the ten rings during that era
That's why he looks so much younger
than he did during the Shang She movie.
no. It's not clear
why they're fighting a younger version of Oden
if he's come to planet Earth to conquer, or there's
some other reason that he's come to planet Earth.
but for instance there was a bunch of footage of solder
that leaked out that might be from this episode,
This footage is actually from a totally different
episode is what if Nebula had joined the Nova Corps?
So that's why she's taking the Nova Corps helmet off.
And you see Yondu, his body lying here?
not exactly sure what she's doing.
This look, she picks up that spear.
It kind of looks like Yondu Spear
from the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
that they were going to keep the power stone
in the actual schematic here
looks a little bit like the Death Star from Star Wars
do with like a super laser port.
love the Watchers joke.
I don't do sequels usually.
Speaking of which, we're actually supposed to get
what if season three?
So hopefully by that time they'll work in some X-Men,
some fantastic Four stuff,
just because we're getting so much
that stuff in the MCU and the live action,
this is just another picture of the 1980s Avengers
king to chock a Black Panther.
This is Howard Stark.
Tony Stark's father, Goliath, obviously
in the background, Peggy Carter, Marvel and Hank Pym.
Ant-Man this is hell inside that village from the Shang
Xi movie, Seeing the Dragon for the first time
this is from a completely different
episode is what if the Avengers formed in 1602.
It's based on the Marvel 1602 comics.
If you haven't read
those is exactly what it sounds like.
It's basically like, what if the Marvel
Universe happened but during the 1600s?
So like all the character relationships are different,
all the organizations are just a little bit different.
is supposedly this is going to be Elizabeth Olsen
coming back to voice her character.
But this is like the old timey version
of Scarlet Witch from the 1600s.
The whole idea in the comics
is that during Marvel 1602,
the Witch Breed were basically the X-Men characters,
and they were the ones being persecuted by the church,
kind of the same metaphor and present day with like
normal people persecuting X-Men for being Mutants.
Anyway, no matter what era is in the Marvel Comics,
X-Men will always be persecuted.
I can't totally tell just from the Red
illumination here because I've seeing them from behind.
But like one of these characters with a K could be
another version of Doctor Strange from that era.
this character with the little wingtips on the Helmet
is probably a version of Thor from that era in
I can't quite tell who it is with the scepter here,
but that could be like a version
of the Infinity Stone from that era.
then this Iron Man episode is like the lost episode
from season one.
We saw the tag for it during season one.
Look at the very end
Gomorrah wound up joining the Multiverse Avengers team,
but Iron Man did not like he was wearing
the junk version of the Hulkbuster, the junk buster,
basically the full episode is called
What If Iron Man Crashed into the Grand Master.
So the whole idea is that something happens
and he gets sent to the car instead of the Hulk.
it basically winds up having to fight
in the contest of champions.
But it's kind of like a mario Kart situation here
not sure how Gamora wound up getting stuck onto the car
here, but like a lot of other familiar characters,
like this is core here.
there's a version of Valkyrie who's
also stuck here as well to
I think part of the idea is they're riffing on the race
from Iron Man to like Iron Man,
who loved racing super fast cars, Jeff Goldblum
Clearly back to Voices character.
The Grandmaster, like I said, this is like the 1980s
version of Ego, the living point,
like the younger looking version of him.
basically fighting that 1980s Avengers team
by creating a bunch of goldens of himself in the desert
here, Notice Thor,
like I said, is the exact same age, or
he looks the same age because he ages so slowly.
these are more scenes of hella basically learning
kung fu in that village from the Shanghai movie.
like if you couldn't tell from the darker liner
around the eyes.
This is meant to be hella
but wearing clothing like they do in that village.
This just looks like Nebula going after Yondu,
who uses his thin in his arrow weapon on her As I said,
this is hell teaming up with Wenwu or the younger
version of Gwen, which is why his hair so much longer.
I'm not sure what year this episode takes place,
just some point
much earlier in the timeline, like way before Shang,
she is ever born
and it looks like Oden is wrecking them
even though they have the ten rings on their side.
I think part of what they were trying to say
in the Shang Shi movie is that when Wu was never
utilizing the ten rings to their full potential,
the way that Shang
she is going to be able to, which is why they glowed
with slightly different energy.
some of the only footage that's a bit of a question
mark is here during the events
of what look like Infinity War because this is like
the modern version of Captain America with the two,
what Condon Shields
he was using during the actual live action
version of Infinity War in Thanos
with the Infinity Gantlet.
Notice
that he does have the entire full gantlet assembled.
this could wind up
being like one of the final episodes.
I think they're like two different episodes
that it seems like Thanos might be in
But at some point during one of the episodes
it seems like it just went up, replaying
some of the events of Avengers Infinity War.
But things are just a little bit different
also not totally sure what episode
this Hulk episode winds up being,
but he has hell of facial hair going on there.
just because he's bathed in red light
that might be from Scarlet Witch is chaos magic.
this episode is the Marvel 1602
like one of the Avengers
for the 1602 episode
because you see them fighting with swords.
And this is Ant-Man.
just because this scene
is the 1602 version of Captain America.
It might be from that fight,
like he might be fighting 1602 Ant-Man.
not sure where this version of rocket shows up
but it's a bunch of dark elves around him.
It could either be the Iron Man episode
because he looks super hardcore.
Then we see Doctor Strange Supreme returning,
and there's an episode called What If Doctor Strange?
Supreme intervened,
and I think that's going to be like the final episode.
sort of
be the culmination of their big multiversal threat.
Like why did the multiverse Avengers
need to form again?
What is the big threat this time?
After the Infinity version of Ultron
This episode is from that special Corey episode.
Basically the idea is that American
Indian winds up finding the tesseract
at a much earlier point in the timeline.
it winds up giving her crazy
infinity stone level powers.
And it just made to show you how the development
of the United States changed pre colonization.
I think it's meant to be before
it was colonized by Great Britain.
like what
if everybody tried to come and colonize America?
But when they did that, the Native Americans
had the power of an infinity stone.
How would that have changed things?
this looks like Captain Carter
and that American Indian character.
And I'm not sure what's going on here with all these
portals that she's opening up in the air.
But because it was the tesseract,
the space stone that gave her powers.
It makes sense
that one of her powers would involve portals.
Killmonger is back at some point.
Just because Captain Carter is fighting Thanos here,
Thanos might wind up being one of their big threats
in one of the final episodes that might be how they get
to that other version of Avengers Infinity War.
More footage with Scarlet Witch.
that I don't know if they took some of this footage
to make the title like
it's from an actual episode
or this is is completely a custom job here
but it's basically the watcher showing captain Carter
about some new big threat.
Then they have a little bit of a funnier episode
and it's basically what if Happy Hogan saved Christmas.
It looks like it's happening in present day
before the events of Avengers Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame because like all of the classic
original six Avengers are there
and we have Darcy with a bunch of cherries there,
so it looks like she's around for the episode.
Do obviously
Jon Favreau is back to do The Voice for Happy Hogan.
She makes a bunch of pop culture movie references.
Connor is a Nicolas Cage movie.
Remember he played ghostwriter in the ghostwriter
movies.
Under siege was a Steven Seagal movie
he then he explains that it's
closer to die Hard because he's crawling
through the vents in a die hard kind of way.
In Die Hard is a Christmas movie for the most part.
it looks like for some reason
Iron Man is dressed up as Santa Claus.
They are the Iron Legion
putting a Santa hat on the Avengers Tower.
So it's after the events of the first Avengers movie
when it became The Avengers Tower.
So like closer to the events of Avengers Age of Ultron
because the Iron Legion exists.
then this is basically the original six Avengers,
or like most of them, like this is Black
Widow dressed up in the background.
Captain America
Iron Man in his armor from that era and Hawkeye.
The only episode from
What if that I didn't see any actual footage from is
what if Captain Carter fought the Hydra Stomper
and they teased that at the end of season one?
It's basically her finding her version of Steve Rogers,
who's turned into that version
of the Winter Soldier For the most part,
this is set in like a different part of the multiverse.
It is technically canon to the MCU.
So like some of these characters
might show up during secret wars for the most part.
Like we saw Captain Carter during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
we saw a slightly different version of Darker
Strange Supreme.
It wasn't this version of Doctor Strange Supreme,
but it was pretty close. but.
Like I said, the episodes start on December 22nd.
I will do videos for all the episodes day to day.
They're going to be nine episodes total,
and they're basically just going to go every single day
until they do all nine.
so that's why we're saying they're doing
kind of like an Advent calendar style release schedule,
which is kind of weird for Marvel,
but they're just trying stuff out like,
Hey, let's get this out before Eko starts.
the other big animated series that they're releasing
early next year sometime will be X-Men 97 episodes.
They didn't say exactly when the release schedule is
going to be, but it'll be some time after it goes done.
If you spotted any other Easter Eggs or references
during the footage that I didn't talk
about during the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Or if you have any big questions about the
what if season 2 episodes.
there's been a bunch of news about like the director
from Avengers Kang Dynasty leaving
and them changing things from like pivoting away
from the Kang character just in general.
So trying to do a video for all that stuff,
at least tomorrow or the day after that.
everyone click here for that brand new Spider-Man
Madam Web trailer, video and Easter Eggs in.
Click here for my Loki season
2 Episode 6 Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!